A world that’s lost its way needs a healer,
someone to patch up its wounds and tend to
its pain.
It needs a doctor.
When day broke, and the sun turned from a
giver of life, the thing that wakes the rooster
and makes the crops grow, to an indiscriminate
killer wiping out all organic life forms.
The world seemed truly lost.
But one anomalous being made it his goal to
soothe the hurt, to make it safe to step into
the light once more.
The Plague Doctor had done his best with the
limited resources afforded to him at the abandoned
Foundation site.
The scientists had left behind all of their
equipment when the red sun came, when they
were transformed.
He had appointed himself the Site Director,
willing to take up the mantle when no one
else would.
He had assembled a brave, brilliant team of
fellow anomalies: the verbose Dr. Spanko,
the eloquent adventurous Lord Blackwood, and
the charismatic but ravenous Fernand.
There had, of course, been those who scoffed
at his vision, who did not share his noble
goal.
The abominable Possessive Mask taunted him
persistently, trying its best to get under
his chitinous skin.
But he did not have time to waste on such
trivial psychological games, and he ignored
its taunts to focus on The Work.
It hadn't been easy, capturing one of the
infected specimens, the former human being
turned mass of oozing gelatinous flesh by
the unholy light in the sky.
One had made its way into the abandoned facility,
sliding its way across the floor with an air
of confused malice.
It wanted to hurt, but it didn't know where
it was, who it was, anymore.
But it was frightened, the Plague Doctor could
tell.
A good physician always knows, and can sense
the fear and pain of a suffering person.
It made his heart ache to see, and he knew
that there was only one thing to do: try to
make this poor soul well again.
"Everyone!
Please assist me in escorting the patient
to my laboratory!"
The Doctor called out.
"This was once a man, and I believe with our
combined intellect and resources, we can return
him to his former state!"
Fernand took a step toward the slimy creature,
licking his lips a bit.
"Do you think I could have just a little bit
of it?
I'm so hungry, Doctor," he begged.
"No!
No, it would go against my oath as a physician
to allow any more harm to come to this poor
fellow."
The Plague Doctor shook his head solemnly.
Fernand pouted, but did not press the issue
further.
"Now," The Doctor rubbed his gloved hands
together in anticipation of the next task.
"It is imperative we contain our new friend
safely.
If you would, please."
He gestured to several of his previous patients,
now reanimated and ready to aid him with his
research.
The shuffling figures surrounded the blobby
entity, ushering it down the hall.
Confused, lost, with no real sense of a plan
left in its mushy consciousness, the creature
followed where it was led.
The group made it back to the Doctor's laboratory.
"Cack!"
Shouted Dr. Spanko, from his perch atop a
nearby shelf.
"Yes indeed!"
The Doctor replied.
"A standard operating table won't do for such
a special patient, I have nowhere to place
the restraints, you see.
I will have to make do with the floor.
Fernand, my bag if you please."
The giant rushed to his side, dropping the
bag at his feet.
"If it dies, then can I eat it?"
He asked, shifting from one foot to the other
like a child asking a parent for a second
helping of ice cream.
"If I am unable to save the patient, which
I do deem unlikely, then...yes, you may help
me dispose of the remains," the Doctor relented.
"But I hope it doesn't come to that."
He pressed a hand to his beak in deep thought
for a moment, before opening his bag and pulling
out a syringe filled with clear liquid.
"To begin, we must sedate the patient."
He had no way to find a vein, and so he plunged
the needle into the nearest section of the
creature's soft surface, injecting a dose
of sedative.
Then, he waited.
The oozing motion of the entity slowed and
stopped.
It lay there on the ground, a still mound
of flesh save for the occasional expanding
and contracting motion, almost as if it was
breathing.
Excellent.
Now that there was no risk of the patient
fleeing the operating room mid-procedure,
he could truly begin.
It was an arduous process that took hours
of effort, of taking small tissue samples,
attempting to make incisions only for the
flesh to fuse back together seconds after
the scalpel was taken away.
This was truly an advanced illness, unlike
anything he had ever seen before.
It was enough to make him question his abilities
as a doctor...but he shook the thought away.
Self-pity never helped anyone.
After about eight hours of continuous work,
he had a breakthrough.
A solution he had created long ago, a thick
green liquid sealed in a dusty jar, had a
miraculous effect when dripped onto one of
the tissue samples.
The melted flesh reconstituted, became solid
and human again.
"Eureka!"
He cried out, unable to restrain the sudden
joy that leaped into his heart.
This could be it.
Very carefully, he filled a dropper with the
green liquid.
If these initial trials had been successful,
then perhaps...
He couldn't finish the thought, best not to
get ahead of himself.
He crossed to his patient, and slowly began
to pour the solution over the creature's viscous
surface.
He watched as the flesh toughened, coming
together into a surface resembling human skin.
It was working...it was working!
But then, the creature began to quiver, shaking
uncontrollably like a bowl of jelly in an
earthquake.
The surface rippled, and the Doctor could
hear a high-pitched whine filling the room.
Then, with a wet pop, the patient exploded,
sending chunks of flesh splattering all over
the room, painting the walls and ceiling.
The Doctor cried out in shock and horror,
and in spite of himself, fell to his knees
in despair.
He had been so close, but still...he had failed.
And who could say when he would find another
test subject?
If he would ever find a cure?
"I'm afraid I do not know what to do now,"
the Doctor admitted.
The next several days passed in a haze.
The Doctor paced around his laboratory, mulling
over his possible mistakes again and again.
He had rushed the process, he was certain
of that now.
It was a novice mistake, the sort of thing
he might have done a century or two ago.
How could he have been so foolish?
How could he have made that innocent pay the
price for his own hubris?
As the Doctor locked himself away in his mind
palace, Fernand occupied himself by practicing
his favorite songs.
Lord Blackwood rode on the massive man's shoulder
as he sang through the opera Don Giovanni.
"I once saw a production of this at the Teatro
La Fenice in Venice!"
Lord Blackwood interjected, his rhinophores
twitching in delight at the memory.
"Marvelous production, marvelous city.
I was there hunting a rogue Tatzelwurm wreaking
havoc along the canals, I nearly lost my life
on that voyage."
"Would you all be quiet for once in your miserable
lives?"
A voice hissed from the shadows.
There, in the doorway, its face fixed in a
frown, was the Possessive Mask.
Black slime dripped from its eyeholes, spilling
down onto the plastic mannequin body it had
taken hold of.
"Listening to you both is worse than being
locked in that infernal box."
The mask looked around the room, searching
for something.
"Where is the good doctor?"
It asked, voice dripping with disdain.
"Still moping about, counting his failures?"
"Ignore him, my fine fellow."
Lord Blackwood whispered to Fernand.
"Only those with weak constitutions and no
achievements of their own spend their days
dragging others down.
When you have lived as long as I, you will
learn this."
"Careful, my Lord."
The Mask laughed a harsh, humorless laugh.
"I'll stop by the kitchen and find some salt
to pour on you."
"If you wish to fight me, then challenge me
to a fair duel like a man!"
The colorful slug bellowed.
Drawn by the sudden shouting, the Doctor walked
into the room.
"What is all this commotion?"
"Oh, good!"
The Mask clapped its plastic hands together,
its face warping back into an eerie smile.
"There you are, this has all been so dreadfully
boring.
I came to see the remnants of your greatest
shame, are there still bloodstains on the
floor in your pathetic little laboratory?"
"You are a villain," the Doctor seethed.
Uncomfortable with the air of conflict in
the room, Fernand and Lord Blackwood quickly
exited, to find another space where they could
sing and share stories in peace.
"I simply speak the truths no one wants to
hear!"
The Mask crossed to the Doctor's side with
a series of light, dance-like steps that made
the mannequin body creak.
"In fact, I have quite a few truths to share
today.
I've been outside, you see.
Whatever's become of the sun only affects
organic beings, and so..."
He gestured from his ceramic face to his plastic
body.
"I am quite safe from its rays."
"You've been outside?"
The Doctor couldn't keep the curiosity out
of his voice.
He was a scientist, after all.
"Why yes.
Would you like to know what I've seen?"
Black slime dripped from the Mask's mouth,
pooling on the floor with a sizzling sound.
"I'm in no mood for tricks," the Doctor warned.
The Mask held up his hands in mock surrender.
"No tricks here, Doctor.
But if you'd rather take your chances outside
and see for yourself, I can take my leave
now..."
"No!"
The Doctor shook his head.
"Please.
Do tell me."
"It is so much worse than you can even imagine."
The Mask's words were bleak, but its tone
was gleeful.
"Everywhere you look out there, the light
has made monsters.
Humans, dogs, cats, mice, the wild beasts
of the forest, all melted down into creatures
you would not even recognize.
But that isn't all!
No, that is not all.
There are massive beasts, ten feet tall or
more, made from dozens and dozens of the creatures
coming together.
They fuse and meld into one giant entity,
roving the streets in search of more and more
bodies to add to the pile, an oozing, gaping
maw of hunger and hate that seeks only to
consume and destroy.
It calls out to surviving humans in the voices
of their fallen loved ones, tugs at their
heartstrings to lure them out of their hiding
places, and then...It wraps around them with
fleshy tentacles, pulling them in until they
are no more.
Just another part of the monster.
Oh, Doctor...it's a terror.
It's an abomination.
I could watch it all day."
The Doctor wanted to believe the Mask was
lying, that it was trying to torment him with
awful fabrications, but after all he had seen
so far...he knew that its words were true.
"Get out of my sight," He said.
"Or what?"
The Mask stared him down with its unmoving
smile.
"I've seen what you do to your hosts, you
know.
Your body won't last forever," the Doctor
growled.
"True.
Maybe next, I'll take yours."
The Mask laughed a long, dark laugh of something
ancient and evil, then it turned and walked
out the door, leaving the Doctor alone.
He spent so much of his time that way, lately.
His assistants were preoccupied, his former
patients provided no real company, and so
he did what he did best: carry on in solitude.
He couldn't be sure how long he stood there
in silence, thinking of what the Mask told
him.
He knew it was dangerous outside, knew he
was up against powerful destructive forces,
but it was even worse than he had thought.
What if the world was truly doomed?
What if this was how it all ended, not with
a bang, but with a great melting?
Suddenly, the Doctor heard a sound he hadn't
heard since the sun turned wrong.
A scream.
A human scream.
Could it be?
He had to see for himself.
He grabbed his bag of tools and rushed down
the hall, his robes fluttering behind him.
There it was, again!
A different human voice, screaming in terror.
As he grew closer to the sound, he could hear
footsteps, various other voices overlapping
with each other.
He rounded a corner, and there they were:
a group of five humans, wrapped in tattered
clothes, dirty and exhausted.
Behind them was the entrance to what looked
like a tunnel.
Somehow they had found a secret passage, and
made their way inside!
Then, he saw what had made them scream.
Clearly, these people were afraid, and unaccustomed
to the sight of a man of Fernand's stature.
Especially when that man was drooling and
staring at them with hunger in his eyes.
He would have to diffuse the situation quickly.
"Hello!
Welcome!
We mean you no harm, strangers!" he stepped
between Fernand and the humans.
A man at the front of the group brandished
a firearm, pointing the barrel directly at
the Doctor's beak.
"Please, sir, there is no need for violence."
"What are you?"
The man stammered.
The other members of his party cowered behind
him.
"An ally, if you will permit me to be.
I am a physician, you see, working on a cure
for the condition that plagues the world."
With a shaking hand, the man slowly lowered
his gun.
He did not put it away, though.
"You've figured out a cure for those...things?"
"I am in the process of developing it.
So far, I have not been successful, but perhaps
with your help?"
"How do we know we can trust you?"
The man demanded.
"How am I supposed to know you're not a part
of this?"
"Do you know who this man is?!"
Fernand bellowed.
"This is Doctor John Watson, and I am Detective
Sherlock Holmes, the greatest investigator
in the world.
There isn't a case we can't solve!"
The man looked at a woman next to him, and
the two shared a wide-eyed glance.
"This guy's crazy..."
He whispered furtively.
"Put your weapon away, and we can speak more
calmly," the Doctor proposed.
At this inopportune moment, a few of his revived
patients shambled into view, and the man screamed
again.
This time, he fired his weapon, shooting at
one of the walking corpses.
The bullets ricocheted off the walls, and
several of the patients were hit.
"Please!
Stop!"
With no other option, the Doctor grabbed the
man's arm, hoping to get ahold of the weapon
and end the potential bloodshed.
As soon as his gloved hand made contact, the
man went limp and dropped to the ground with
a hard thud.
The woman next to him pulled him into her
arms, checking his pulse.
"He's dead!"
She shrieked, tears streaming down her face.
"I...I am so sorry, my Lady, I did not intend..."
She grabbed the man's gun and trained it on
the Doctor once more.
"You killed him!"
She cried.
The other survivors were too shaken to speak,
to move.
One of them had his back turned to the group,
and was staring into the darkness of the tunnel
behind him.
Whatever he was looking at, it was worse than
the chaos unfolding.
But no one noticed the beige flesh tentacle
snaking along the ground until it was too
late.
Until it had grabbed ahold of the man's ankle
and dragged him into the tunnel with a shriek
of pure, unadulterated terror.
The woman nearly dropped her gun at the sound,
whirling around to see what had happened.
Deep in the tunnel, the scream warped into
a wet gurgling sound, and then there was silence
for a long moment.
But then, something worse.
A gooey, slimy sound, the sound of something
enormous, something soft and fleshy, making
its way through the tunnel and toward the
group.
Another tentacle curled around the edge of
the opening, then another joined it.
Something emerged that might have once been
a hand, but had melted into something unrecognizable.
The monster emerged piece by piece, until
the Doctor could see the entire thing.
It looked like a heap of people, dozens of
them, clambering on top of each other, wrapping
their limbs together until their flesh and
insides emptied out and fused into a shapeless
mass.
It moved a bit like a giant slug, slimy and
slow, but it seemed to know it could take
its time.
As the survivors scrambled back away from
it, Fernand and the Doctor taking a few steps
back of their own, the sound of human voices
filled the room.
There were unintelligible whispers, the soft
giggle of a child, a woman weeping.
"Come and be with us..."
A little boy's voice broke through the cacophony.
"Mommy...I miss you, don't you miss me?"
The woman with the gun let out a broken sob.
"Billy?"
She sniffled.
"It's me, mommy..."
The innocent voice continued, emanating from
somewhere deep inside the monstrous mass that
crept along the ground, swelling and grasping
with its ropy tentacles.
"Come play with me, outside...
All you have to do is come outside..."
"Madam, the creature is not who it claims
to be," the Doctor spoke up, and it seemed
to shake the woman out of a trance.
"You're not my son," she hissed, squeezing
the trigger and firing at the monster.
The bullet made contact with a wet, useless
slap, and disappeared into the roving pile
of the fallen.
She fired again, and again, but the monster
did not stop.
It didn't even slow down.
It lashed out with a tentacle that wrapped
around her throat in a single fluid motion,
and snapped her neck with a crack.
She fell to the ground, and the tentacle pulled
her into its depths until she was no longer
visible.
She hadn't been taken by the sun, not yet,
but she was still lost.
The rest of the survivors followed, their
screams silenced one by one.
The Doctor felt the same overwhelming sense
of hopelessness wash over him, the same shadow
that had passed over him when he lost the
last patient.
What could he do?
He was one physician against an overpowering
force of destruction.
Perhaps he could touch it, and it would fall
dead like so many other organisms before?
But what if it didn't?
What if instead it wrapped around his body
and squeezed the life from him?
What if it carried him out into that cursed
sunlight and he melted away like the others?
He had to make a decision, because the beast
was advancing toward him.
"Doctor!"
Fernand shouted.
"It's going to destroy our facility!"
Indeed, the creature was flailing its appendages
around, beating against the walls and trying
to tear down steel and plaster, break down
the shelter until they too were exposed to
the deadly light.
"I'm afraid this may be the end, my friend,"
the Doctor lamented.
"I can see no hope for us now."
"No."
Fernand shook his head.
"Let me save us.
Let me lead it back outside."
"You'll be taken!"
The Doctor cried.
"Perhaps not!
I am a magnificent specimen, after all.
I believe I can withstand the sun, and return
to continue our work together," Fernand scooped
a sleeping Lord Blackwood from his shoulder
and placed him gingerly on a nearby shelf.
"Thank you for your company."
Then he turned back to the Doctor.
"And thank you for my freedom.
And your friendship.
It has been an honor."
Before the Doctor could protest, Fernand was
running, his thunderous steps pounding the
earth as he led the monster in a chase.
It took the bait, following this new, large
target back outside.
He sealed off the tunnel behind them, ensuring
the beast would not return the way it came.
He wanted to believe Fernand's bravado, to
think that the behemoth of a man had survived
outside.
But that night, he saw the great beast ooze
past a window, and could make out that familiar
wide, toothy grin protruding from its side.
Just like that, the greatest assistant he
had ever had was lost.
"Thank you for your service, my friend," He
whispered to himself.
"I solemnly swear to you, your death shall
not be in vain..."
Now go check out “When Day Breaks SCP-049”
and “When Day Breaks SCP-096” for more
terrifying tales from the world of When Day
Breaks!